&gt;&gt; Awesome. We have a solution. Actually, we have two solutions. We have two
different values of x, either of which would make this equation true. At any
given time, we don't use both of them. As always when we're substituting in
values for variables, we're consistent about what we plug in. If we're going
with x equals negative 30, we put that in every spot where x is. Let's just
double-check to make sure that this is what we want to have happen. The
left-hand side of the equation, if we plug in x equals negative 30, will end up
being 0 times negative 35. Even though this factor over here is not 0, anything
times 0 is 0. Something very similar happens if we plug in x equals 5, but I'll
leave that up to you. And the question is, considering what x stands for,
remember, it's the length that we're adding to each side of Grant's booth, only
one of these two answers really mean makes sense. Thinking about what x stands
for in our original equation, remember it's the length that Grant wants to add
in feet to each side of his display booth at the expo, only one of these two
answers really makes sense. So, pick one of them, and tell me how much longer
each side of the booth should be.